I really messed up this time would you  do Helen I let Donald Trump sign my  Bible yes that's sacrilege that's you  call I know I don't know that much so  you got caught up in the moment  mesmerized by his hair his mane rests on  the way he fills a pair of khakis you  let the game show host president sign  your holy book don't worry there's hell  Barack you clean Bible wipes get to the  source of sinners signatures and with  one part rubbing alcohol and one part  divine intervention  get your Bible back to heaven way  cleaner thank God for morality will it  work on an autograph on my left breast  what rank you p1 Bible wipes available  at all Christian pro shops and  participating Hobby Lobby locations  did you notice those actors looked up at  the sky long before that lightning  struck I'm sorry if you it's worth going  back and looking at it's one of those  things that obsesses me a good three  minutes before the lightning strikes